[Musique]
un des meilleurs ou au pire faire de
l'histoire de la
Macarena
la première version de la Macarena para
los del Rio est sorti en 1992 à l'époque
elle remporte un certain succès dans des
pays latins
une version des Canadiens quand qu'ils
ont pris quand c'est arrivé chez nous un
peu avant et après ça a été aux
États-Unis et c'est là que ça à
l'échelle mondiale parce que j'étais un
peu d'anglais
immense repris en version Stéphanie
revisiter à la trappe
[Musique]
ou même comme Chanel
et là
actuellement il y a la maison ou Lego on
vu la fille qui a inspiré une danseuse
de flamenco
c'est dans cette maison si que la
Macarena été créé ce qu'ils ont vu la
danseuse en question se nourrit la
maison
[Musique]
c'est quand que si chaque dessiner avec
sa chanson latino avec des mouvements
danser les gens prennent plaisir à
apprendre à la fin des années 80 il y a
eu la lambada
dans les années 2000
[Musique]
comment avec plusieurs chantant qu'un
TDM des TIC la chorégraphie facile
les enfants les parents les
grands-parents
[Musique]
c'est que c'est paroles Nabilla
pour les enfants parce que ça parle
d'une fille qui est une grande
séductrice est infidèle et qui dit bah
si tu danses bien à mes côtés il va
peut-être se retrouver dans mon lit
espagnol continue de surfer sur le
succès de la
Macarena